- [Mark] All right, Norman.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Welcome back.
- Glad to be back.
- [Mark] So what's the latest with you?
- Well, the latest is, for
those who wanted to know,
did I nail the interview that Monday?
Yeah, I kicked its ass.
I'm currently working for this company.
We're not getting paid yet.
I'm in the training process
because after I finished
the training process,
we'll be tested and I'll be
getting what you call a CPM,
which is a certified property
management certificate.
And that's pretty good.
You know, I'm working,
it's a 35-unit building.
They housed veterans with severe PTSD.
85% of them are ex-addicts
or using addicts now because
they have harm reduction
that's put in place.
So that within itself is a blessing.
You know, how do I get to a
point to where God blesses me
to move away from that in order
to move me into a position
and a situation where
people are just like me
and may need a helping hand.
- [Mark] Who better than you?
- You know, I mean, you
talk about grateful,
I'm grateful that God has bestowed upon me
to even have a job.
This place gave me a brand
new laptop that I work on.
I haven't sold it.
They trusted me, they're entrusting me.
And the blessing about that
is that nobody trust me.
I didn't even trust myself.
And there are some times
where I don't trust myself.
But God is there.
Situation being the other day,
I was coming home and the
police were chasing the guy,
and he dropped his dope sack.
And I'd seen it.
Now immediately, the
addict mind kicked in.
Norman, look, you ain't got no money.
Times are tough.
You sober, you can take
this, you can sell this.
And it just went on and on for a minute.
And I had, all I said was God, be with me.
I walked past it.
And when I turned around,
another car was coming around the corner,
they opened the door
and they went right straight to that sack.
See, just because I'm
sober and I'm not using,
doesn't mean that the
addict mind doesn't kick in.
It kicked in.
But most importantly, I
did something about it.
The best thing I could do about it: pray.
Because usually I wouldn't
believe in prayer.
Remember, God and I had a problem.
Now we don't.
I called on him.
He helped me and walked me through it.
That was very important for me,
because if I would have took that
and those police came around
that corner, I'm gone.
I wouldn't be talking to you right now.
So thank God for that.
The job is, how would I put this?
It's nourishing for me.
You know, because it's an older building
that was restored and it's 35 units.
It's pretty small, but it's really nice.
But I'm able to help some people.
I'm able to be of service.
You know, if you don't know
low income tax credits,
HUD housing, and things like that,
it'd be a very difficult job.
Luckily, God has blessed me to work
for companies in the
past doing this stuff,
which led me to a position
where I know exactly what I'm doing.
They've given me five tests already.
I scored 100% on all five.
It's not bragging.
It's not trying to toot my own horn.
But thank God I got the ability
to even go through a test.
'Cause I know that I have the aptitude
and the ability to do it.
But what about those times
where I just said no.
Sometimes I think about those times.
It's Christmas time,
and of course, I miss my mom.
I miss my grandmother.
I miss my family in
general, but it's okay.
It's a little hard right now,
because they cut the food stamp thing off.
I'm not getting paid from the job
but I'm still working, but it's okay.
And know why it's okay?
Because God dammit exactly
what it's supposed to be.
See, and I respect it more
because I remember those
times where I disrespected it
and didn't care.
See, usually I'd be running
around acting a fucking fool,
but I'm not.
It's not that I'm
self-centered or self-seeking.
I'm just into doing the
best that I can right now,
one day at a time.
Because futuristically when I look further
than I'm supposed to, I fuck up.
So God is allowing me
to learn from my past.
I don't have to hold
on to it, like I have.
I don't have to use it
as an excuse, as I have.
But I can learn from it.
Because I remember those times.
I still have a place
to stay with my buddy.
We have a little food.
We're gonna get some
more, somehow some way.
- [Mark] You're in a tent still?
- [Norman] Huh?
- [Mark] You're in a tent?
- No, I'm in Donald's,
I'm still at Donald.
- [Mark] Oh wait so, you have a little...
- Yeah, we got the
refrigerator we got, yeah.
We don't have a lot, but I
thank God for the minimal.
And the other day I was thinking,
because for two days I was thinking about
thank God for the minimum.
Thank God for the minimum.
And so when I went into my
meditation the other morning,
I sat. because I go in a
Little Tokyo in Los Angeles,
and I sit by this pond that
has these goldfish, you know,
and they're very therapeutic for me.
And I kept thinking, I was like,
why do you want me to to appreciate,
to be grateful for the minimum.
And what came to me was so
you'll appreciate the maximum.
So if I'm grateful for the minimum,
I'll more so appreciate
the maximum when it comes.
I won't be selfish and self-centered,
I'll be conscious enough
to know that, guess what,
I moved from here to here.
And I did it with God's help.
Not about me, It's not all about me.
You know, my friend is struggling
and he's really struggling, man.
And it hurts
because I live with him.
And to watch somebody just,
man, just tear themselves down.
I try.
I try my best,
but as God has instituted
in me to do one thing,
and one thing only, be my shining light.
Norman, it's gonna happen when it happens.
Of course it hurts me,
'cause that's my friend, you know.
Out of everybody, even
when I was down and out,
he let me in his house.
I didn't have any fucking food.
He had a minimal, very
minimal amount of food.
He gave me something to eat.
He allowed me to wash my ass.
He let me sleep on his floor.
Still he's doing this.
So I'm gonna pray for him.
I'm not gonna excuse myself for crying
because sometimes some people say,
well man's not supposed to cry.
Well, what the fuck I have tear ducts for?
Why do I have emotions?
You know, I love that brother
'cause he's a good brother.
And all I want, you know,
is the best for him.
So it'll happen when it happens there.
- [Mark] Yeah, just because you want it
doesn't mean he's ready.
- Yeah, it has to come in his time.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- So the other day I ran
into a good friend of mine
who went through elementary school with me
from kindergarten to sixth grade.
And he was really struggling,
but he knew who I was.
Now, you're talking 40 plus years ago.
And I asked him, I said,
"Hey man, how you doing?"
And he says, "Man, this
crystal meth and this crack.
It's tearing me apart."
He said, "My marriage is gone,
and everybody just doesn't
wanna be bothered with me."
And I asked him, I said,
"Why do you do it?"
He said,
"Because I really just don't
wanna deal with anything."
I said, "Well, just do me a favor."
I said, "Take my number
down and call me, anytime."
I said, "I want you to know this."
I said, "I don't know how long I have."
I said, "But I've been
clean for a little minute."
Just a little minute.
I don't know how long because
I don't count the days.
I said, "Just believe in God
and ask him to take it away from you."
And he said, "Okay."
His mom called me this morning.
- [Mark] Good.
And that woman said, you know,
"I just wanna thank you."
She said, "I don't remember you."
His mother is 90 plus years old.
She said, "I don't remember you.
But he told me you guys
went to school together."
She said, "Whatever you
said to my son, thank you."
And I said, "Well, you know."
She says, "No, honey.
Whatever you said to that
boy, it touched him."
She said, "Iban has not
touched anything in four days."
And, you know, I'm a
very emotional guy, man.
You know, I cry like a baby,
like I got tears in my eyes now.
Because, you know,
coming from me, come on,
you know the crack head
Norman, one check Norman,
smoke up everything Norman.
How the fuck do you put me in the position
to where I wasn't
looking at doing anything
but just saying a kind word.
And his mom called me
and she said a prayer
for me on that phone.
My buddy wasn't there.
I cried like a baby.
And I just thank God for putting
me in a position like this,
to be his shining light
and to do his bidding and not my own.
I just wanna help people,
which in turn helps me, you know.
Even the negative comments.
Some people say, well you
haven't done anything.
Well, guess what?
That's your opinion.
As long as I feel within myself
that I've done something,
and I have all these positive comments,
the positive always outweighs
the negative, you know.
So I'm gonna keep on keeping on.
I'm gonna keep on doing
exactly what I'm doing
in order to get where I need to go.
I don't know where I need to go.
I know where I would want to go,
but God knows exactly where I'm going.
So I'll just ride that train.
And with that, everybody
have a good holiday.
You know, eat enough, don't get sick.
Thank you very much for your prayers
and your just being you.
Thank you so very much.
- [Mark] Excellent, Norman.
Thank you very much, man.
You look great.
- Thank you.
That shit broke my fucking heart, man.
That lady and she was crying
and I'm like, oh my God.
She said "Whatever you said to him."
Yeah, he's been clean for four days.
- [Friend] He remembered
me from fucking...
We were in class from
kindergarten to 6th grade!
- [Mark] But isn't it great
to be able to help somebody like that?
- [friend] Yeah!
(voices fading)